vous venez de l'entendre un navire de
guerre ukrainien s'est approché à des
eaux russes d'après le fsb et ce en
faisant fi des avertissements des
garde-côtes qui lui demander de faire un
demi-tour on évoque du côté de moscou
une provocation l'équipage ukrainien
ouvriers toutefois argué qu'il n'avait
pas l'intention de passer à danser au
les précisions sur place de lolya
chapeau va nova les correspondants de
rtl internationale
pas très loin de l'autre avec je me
tiens en ce moment dans la vie de pierre
jean crime et une collision entre les
fautes russes et ukrainiennes dans le
détroit de kertch a été évitée
selon le fmi l'incident a commencé le 9
décembre à nous surtout et nathan quand
le navire ukrainien donbass à quitter
les ports de marie paule et a commencé à
se déplacer vers le détroit de cash dans
selon la partie russe une requête de
passage n'a été reçue pour ce qui est
nécessaire conformément à la nation
pendant ce kanye west la partie
ukrainienne assure que le navire n'avait
pas l'intention de passer par le votre
angle qu'il n'y avait pas d'armes où il
navigue les dans la mer d'azov dans la
direction du détroit de kertch ans et
plus tard pendant la journée a mis le
cap sur le chemin du registre mais ne
répondait toujours pas aux demandes de
la gare frontalière russe si c'est ainsi
que le fsb prévoit des fonds
les services spéciaux russes ont
considéré les actions de l'équipage que
l'on trouvait le là sans la sécurité de
la navigation la partie ukrainienne a
déclaré de son côté ne pas être entrée
dans des zones sensibles effectuant
seulement détail dans ses propres eaux
territoriales et ensuite s'en est
retourné à la base on dort selon la
ministre ukrainien de la défense dans sa
cote dombass et des dans la mer d'azov
d'antoine d'égalité car il s'agit
il s'est dit sûr pas du fait que moscou
est considérée comme une menace un
navire de sauvetage sans abri selon les
analystes à l'aller les ukrainiens avec
le soutien de l'occident et s'est
régulièrement de violer les eaux
territoriales russes les autorités de
leur exprimer leurs préoccupations et
appelle un conseil de sécurité de l'onu
elle discrète et son problème
susceptible de mener à une plus large
aux fondations